I have seen every episode, every minute of Top Chef,
and you won the whole enchilada,
and I love your new show, Fast Foodies.
Will you tell us about it?
Yes. So, Fast Foodies is equal parts
comedy, fun, creativity.
I mean, we're taking some of the most simple things
in the entire world -fast food, guilty pleasures,
and we're turning them into like the most creative,
imaginative things you'll ever see.
So, you know, strap yourselves in
'cause it is one heck of a fun ride,
and it's all the guilty pleasures you'll never
ever stop eating,
because everyone loves fast food.
Well, let's say that my very favorite fast food moment
in my personal history is the McDonald's Filet-O-Fish.
(Audience cheers)
Amazing!
And I've got a real one right here.
And one on the things that I love so much
on your new show, Fast Foodies, is
you will imitate a classic, kinda knock it out in the park,
and show people how to do it for themselves
or how it can be done.
But then you also do interpretations
with your own spin.
Um, because we don't want just imitation,
we want innovation.
So, teach me, Jeremy. Teach me anything you want.
I'm all ears.
Yes, Drew. So, are you ready?
Are you ready for this?
I've never been more ready in my life, actually.
I'm exited. All right. Tell me what to do.
Okay. So. Um. Very simple.
We're going to work on the tartar sauce.
I want you take the mayonnaise
Yep.
The pickle relish.
The capers.
And then I'm gonna be putting a little bit of lemon zest.
About the le-
And I think, by doing that,
you get like this -yes-
you-you've used this before.
(Jeremy laughs)
I do love a zesting.
And then, um. A little trick I like to show is
to get no seeds in your lemon,
what I do is I cut just in front of the seeds on the side.
Straight down.
And, look at that.
You never have to deal with those pesky seeds.
And then now, just take that side,
I call it like the ear of lemon,
and I squeeze that ear right into our tartar sauce
and then, this will just need to be mixed a little bit.
So now that we have that done,
we're going to move on to the fish portion of this,
which is super simple.
I want you to take your beautiful cod filet,
and we're gonna go straight in to egg wash.
Now, go to the bread crumb.
Give it a little shake.
Yes, and then, make sure that you get every little crevice
with the bread crumb.
So, pound it on the sides, a little bit on the bottom.
Okay. So now, we can drop it in the oil very gently.
So, once- what we do now is, this will cook on each side
for about two minutes.
Um, and then, we're gonna take it out,
put it on to a nice, uh, towel,
so it can dry that excess oil.
And we're just gonna put a little bit
of this thick fleur de sel.
It's like a thick salt that I love,
and it just-
it looks like there's a lot of salt in there,
but trust me, it is like the best salt ever,
and I stand behind it.
These are gorgeous. I wanna just get into them right now.
(Jeremy laughs)
Okay.
Okay. So, now we can build our delicious Filet-o-Fish
that you love so dearly.
Okay. So, we take our bun -bottom half,
and then we're doing like,
I call it the three-quarter-ven-cheese-method.
Because if you put the full slice,
it's gonna like melt over the bread,
and it looks weird.
So, I take like just like,
I don't know, like fifteen percent of it,
and just get rid of it.
Let's put this on the bottom of the bottom bun.
Just like this.
Okay. Perfect.
So then we're gonna put our hot crispy fish
right on top of that cheese to try to kinda get it to melt
a little bit.
Uh hmm.
And then tartar sauce that you made
with your fancy micro bladed lemon zest.
Yep.
Now, the bun on top.
All right. So, now I can bring them together?
Yes.
Okay
(Audience applause)
Um. Okay. I'm- I'm just gonna be perfectly blunt.
I just want to try it. Are we ready?
Cheers!
Cheers, Jeremy!
(Audience cheers)
So lovely to cook with you.
(moans)
Oh my God!
This is incredible. (moans in delight)
You know what's funny?
Cheese and fish, typically don't go well together.
For some reason, this is a magical combination.
McDonald's got it right.
And I just love it.This is so exciting.
And everybody, like, get your plate,
get your food, and watch Fast Foodies.
It's on truTV. It is the best show.
Thank you so much. Thank you, Jeremy!
This was such-
I love you, Drew!
I love you, Jeremy!
(theme song plays)